let's jump to the story let's uh we'll
shift here from the daily mail democrat
civil war over student loans explodes
but in his blast that is out of touch
and told he is punishing those without a
degree by his own party as new
projections say it will cost americans
500 billion dollars this is um
maybe a white pill moment
joe biden wanted to pander to
progressives the problem is the
democratic party is split between the
establishment moderate types in the far
left joe biden can't win he goes and
says okay fine i'll give you some
student loan forgiveness which he
doesn't really have the author i don't
believe he has the authority to actually
do this it's a matter for congress and
then they're trying to claim he's got an
emergency ability to do it the left says
it's not enough what is this you know
they're happy with some of it but it's
not enough the democrats are now coming
after them being like you are giving
money to to the highest income earners
in this country it's an insult to
taxpayers it's an insult to the working
class and it's an insult to those who
did not take out loans because they
received no benefit and the republicans
are sitting there going uh-huh exactly
so this sounds like
the democrats are going to get crushed
come november they were looking good in
some in in that new york 19 special
election then biden comes out and does
this
the left they don't like joe biden
leftists do not like joe biden he's not
going to win them over all he's doing is
pissing off the swing districts that to
me is crazy
but it sounds like
the way things are going
well republican i don't like how they
phrased this article here democrats
civil war i don't like that they're
softening that term civil war i feel
like we're doing a real disservice to
our species if we do that because civil
war is not a good thing even in metaphor
well they're just conditioning you to
hear the word silva more more so when it
starts happening you know it's like oh
it's been around for a while we've been
in it for a little bit you know
secondly i just posted on twitter
earlier i'm having issues with this loan
repayment thing because i have i'm in
this bracket under a hundred thousand
dollar salary it's like hundred thousand
dollar salary uh
25 000 in student loans probably 8 000
of it or 10 000 of it is interest unpaid
that's accrued over the last 20 years
i'm not comfortable taking this money if
they're going to print it from the
federal i'm not i will not take this
money if they print it from the federal
reserve i don't know do you have to
apply for it i don't know there's a
website i heard that's already down here
yeah that sounds right
i'm not going to do this to my fellow
americans man they do not deserve to pay
my bill it's insane this is the craziest
thing too it's like
a bunch of conservatives are coming out
saying like this is wrong student
student debt forgiveness is wrong
and then the left is responding by
showing screenshots of them having
accepted ppp loans
i think it's weird that they took ppp
loans i'm gonna be honest i know there
was a reason to do it there was market
stagnation and you know people don't
want to go under but i kind of look at
some of these companies and i'm like oh
these companies make a lot of money do
they really need it because i'll tell
you this tim cast did not either
yeah
daily wire didn't do it they did not no
and in fact they were circulating a
screenshot of a guy named ben shapiro
far and wide saying look at this the
daily wire took ppp funds they never did
the daily wire made a point of never
taking any ppp loans in fact if you like
look at the full screenshot of this ben
shapiro he's actually a real estate
agent so like no i didn't do that he's a
real estate agent yeah exactly it's like
they're just lying they're lying tim
cast uh i will say this i
outright was like no way i'm not going
anywhere near that you know why because
i knew it's like for one it's it's all
publicly available information and i'm
like i don't want that money i don't
need that money i would rather take the
hit and then dip into the red and have
to go into our rainy day funds or
whatever then accept you know these ppp
loans or whatever it's because they're
printing it they're they're devaluing
our currency by doing if they were like
going to the the loan companies and
saying okay you're not getting your
usurious inc interest back because it
was unethical in the first place that
i'd be fine with then i'm like yeah
let's erase what they think they deserve
but i'm not gonna tax the the citizens
by printing more that's crazy
intuition's just going to go up more
yeah that's how this works there's a
meme where it's uh
it's it's that meme of the guy and he's
like looking all happy and it says when
they forgive 10k in student loan debt
and the next one is him looking shocked
and it says when your tuition goes up
10k next year yeah
dude if you know so biden apparently is
saying like we got to make sure they
can't raise tuition but you can't like
what can you really do and if you're if
if i'm a business
and i sell you know i don't know with
ufos or whatever and the guy oh no how
about this i have a business we sell
memberships over at timcast.com
signing up today if the government came
out and said they were going they're
going to cover 10
of everyone's memberships if they had
one i'd be like
oh it's 20 now of course
this would happen i mean honestly i
wouldn't do that but that's kind of the
idea of any business they'd be like okay
because for the average person they're
not getting hurt because the
government's subsidizing it it is
hurting everybody because it's stripping
money from everybody to pay for a few
and there's also an argument i mean what
about the people already paid off their
student loans we have uh
we have a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars left from my life students loans
and we've been paid on now for uh 12
years you know and even if the money
were offered to us we're not in the
bracket or whatever but in the money
we're offered to us like i would take it
because i know where it's i know where
it's going to be paid from and we keep
bankrupting we have kids i'm i don't
leave my kids more debt than what we
started with
yeah and it's not gonna be the last time
they do this so is it is it a one-time
thing how many times are you gonna
forgive ten thousand dollars they also
money they did this thing where there's
a there's like a ten percent cap and
they're getting there this is a major
move towards outright free free college
what they're saying is already i think
after 20 years the loans dissolve and
are forgiven or something like that
and then they're saying there's a max
cap of like 10 percent of your income
can be paid towards it now they've
reduced it to percent i could begin that
wrong it's something like that it's on
it's on their website and so already
they're basically eliminating people's
student loan loan debt
look
on paper i'm totally in favor of debt
forgiveness and um i just think that if
you're going to go for student loans
let's start with mortgages too let's
like let's let's let's you know
alleviate that for a lot of people trade
school trade school whatev whatever your
debt may be and um here's my here's why
i see it
all right you want to give everybody 10k
for their student loans everyone else
gets a 10k tax credit everyone yeah and
you can't discriminate for this but i
will say the way they're going about it
is wrong
what i would say is
interest payments should be forgiven
because interest is where it's like
people pay people someone takes out a 50
000 loan and then 10 years later they're
like i've paid 70 thousand dollars back
and oh 30. and it's like what like how
does that make sense you've given way
more than inflation and principal
i think people have to pay back their
principles you don't get free money
there should be some interest for
inflation but not this insane
compounding bs
and uh that's a place to start however
the real place you start is ending the
loan system
just shutting it down none of that but i
don't know i i i do want to say the main
point of this is not to talk about
student loans to talk about republicans
winning in november because if
everyone's getting pissed off about this
well how much of this is just a bribe
too like 10 000 not the 50 000 they
promised maybe it's just like a well we
got to do something how much of it is
just to bribe for voters well if he was
smart biden he'd say
we're gonna give out i'm gonna sign an
order ten thousand dollars and then you
know when when next congress
you know we're gonna come together and
and and figure out how to do
if the democrats win
and then people are going to be like
there's the bribe and that's like that's
the smart way to go about doing it maybe
he'll come out and say it and say i know
people are unhappy think 10 10 wasn't
enough
in the next session of congress they can
approve more or something like that
that's where as the dealer you give them
a little taste
get them all excited and then say you
want more now you got to pay and that
would be in the form of hey vote for us
so there's that famous quote by that
dude i can't remember his last name it's
like tocqueville or something and he
said the american republic will persist
until congress learns that it can bribe
the american people with their own money
yep and that's where we're headed dare
we say biden is maybe revealing a
pattern
one might even think he
might not be a great father or
grandfather maybe he tries to solve
problems by throwing money over the line
i'm basing this on nothing i just get
the feeling i'm looking at the the fruit
of the tree his kids turned out fine
yeah yeah you know i i just i see a
pattern maybe
if we connect some dots i don't know i
don't know that's illegal i think i
think questioning uh joe joe biden's
parental abilities is is a step over the
line george and um we we here at tim
cast do not tolerate the besmirching
such an honorable man perhaps he should
throw me some money too
no i'm just kidding
but no i mean really this does
this does frighten me as a person who's
just watching if if their solution and
i'll throw this at the whole democrat
party whatever if your solution is to
throw money at a problem instead of
looking at the root of the problem and
trying to solve
for instance a lot of people are
accepted into college who may be
i i dare to say this they don't belong
there and they there's this whole
industry of just putting butts in seats
because it makes the colleges look like
there's they're this exploding business
there's lots of people going to school
you get a lot of crap degrees that mean
basically nothing flooding the market
with people a labor force who really
don't deserve to have these degrees i
dare to say so they just kind of fail
their way through college
they accept loans from whatever people
are going to give you i don't know i'm
going to give you a loan and you're
going to pay me this much an interest in
a few years they can't pay it because
they can't find work
inflation's happening so now those loans
are basically i don't know what's
happening to the value of the loan but
you still have to pay the interest we
the taxpayers are going to be left with
the bill anyway maybe that was the plan
for the beginning but there's this this
fake industry of uh
i'm a college dropout so i'm biased but
i don't believe in this idea of i own
a piece of paper that says i'm qualified
therefore you should hire me as opposed
to i'm just a hard-working person hey
maybe apprentice me hire me for a few
years
and then i'll be qualified it's not even
that i mean look man
if uh i i said we need to commission
some art
and then you know uh adam comes over
here and he says i have an art degree
i'd be like that's great
yeah where's the art and you bet well i
don't have any but i have a degree that
that shows you that i know how to do it
and then you know george comes over here
he's like here's a picture of my art who
am i going to hire
the artist the guy who has a picture i'm
like i like how that looks make me one
of those not the guy who's got a piece
of paper and a degree and who paid tens
of thousands of dollars to have that
piece of paper which doesn't necessarily
prove that you're able to do any of this
stuff which is i think we're being sold
our generation especially was sold this
idea of you have to go to college in
order to get a job yes absolutely
employers were convinced that there was
value to that piece of paper leaving
people like i'm sorry i'm a little
bitter about it leaving people like me
who i think you know i was very hard
working and stuff and i really wanted to
do what i did you know comics and stuff
but i don't think a lot of places even
considered me um when i was you know
sending my cv to people they didn't even
consider me as a candidate
that's also made a high school diploma
worthless yeah so a lot of kids are you
know they're pretty much decided by 9th
or 10th grade if they're going to
college or not you know they kind of
check i mean i know i was that way when
i grew up i was in high school i didn't
really have a lot of interest in going
to college so i kind of just played
video games and hung out you know and
now having kids you know there's that
social pressure is like i have to go to
college because i want my kids to go to
college and i know it's just it's social
engineering and i'm supposed to want to
do that because good fathers do that
they make sure their sons have good
degrees and they can take care of their
kids yeah i i have to agree with george
i think that this is fully systemic and
i think it stems from the problem of
encouraging kids i think the reason we
have so much under underwater basket
waiting and so much student loan debt
right now is because kids have been told
that college is the only way to go this
is what you're supposed to do exactly
exactly and then they're told this is
the way you're supposed to earn money
and for a certain time so people people
got their connection backwards just a
little bit like the self-esteem issue
that i talk about sometimes they thought
that people who got college degrees
earned more money because they were more
committed to their job because their
degree it was like a big blob it was
very important that all these things
went together the fact of the matter was
that the people who were super committed
would be the ones who would end up going
to college for that specialty and then
who would end end up going into that
profession and being really
focused and really talented what they
were doing well high school doesn't
really specialize you or set you up to
go into college right you know right so
it trains you to go to college it trains
you to go to teaches you how to school
right but anyone who's got an
associate's degree will tell you the
first two years of college or the last
few years of high school you know but
again the high school diploma was
meaningless now so maybe a solution is
to make high school meaningful these
kids after ninth or tenth grade could be
taking a two year apprenticeship program
and be coming out as a plumber's
assistant or an electrician assistant we
can we can make meaningful uh solutions
with public high school 100 i just don't
see that i don't see the desire for them
to do that because they want you to go
to college no and the scary thing is
that i see this pattern for the past few
years but it's been happening for a long
time of borrowing from the future so we
can pay the bills of today
our kids are going to
inherit this i don't even know what to
call it
someone's going to pay this bill it's
it's maybe going to be us in 10 20 years
i don't know maybe they're going to try
to sell alaska to somebody or something
but where is this money going to come
from well they could just print more
have we tried that no we have to you're
right just print more let's do that
wasn't it march of 2020 that fractional
reserve banking ended and it went
infinite reserve yeah you can print they
can print as much as they want now
that's fine
it used to be fantastic you could you
could issue a loan creating money up to
was it ninety percent of your holding
yeah and then yeah the way it would work
is like i put a hundred dollars in bank
of ian ian then issues a loan for ninety
dollars to george but he still has the
hundred the ninety dollars is created
upon issuance of the loan then george
gives me the 90 and then i create you
know
well george then can take that 90 that
so tim you give me a hundred i have a
hundred i can give you 90. i keep my
hundred you take you keep your 90 but
you can loan out 81 to someone else they
can keep their 81 but they can loan out
17.
exactly he then deposits in another bank
and then issue another loan but no it's
crazy scheme it's crazier than that in
march of 2020 they basically said you
don't need reserves anymore i can i can
loan you 10 million you can loan 10
million of that i wonder if you can loan
11 million of your 10 million banks can
just literally snap their fingers and
write money to anybody it's a game of
hot potato someone's going to be left
holding it or musical chairs or whatever
it's it's it's sort of but it's a game
of hot potato that like while the hot
potato game is playing someone is like
they're they're juggling a bunch of
potatoes and then the rich people are
like chucking the potatoes into a box
behind them when no one's looking and
then they're like okay guys i'm leaving
you keep playing the game i don't and
then they walk away with a box full of
potatoes yeah it's gonna be a silly
purse that ended up paying it i mean i i
definitely think it's going to go down
to a two-class system the middle class
continues to shrink and i think what
they're afraid of is generational wealth
right it's very difficult to amass
generational wealth to set yourself up
and i think the problem is with
generation wealth is that you eventually
start gaining power and influence and
the less people that can have power and
influence the less we can change the
system
i just saw that paypal is changing their
terms of service so that soon like
within a month you're not going to be
able to send money to an offshore
uh business and an offshore business is
not going to be able to send money to
your personal paypal account so that
makes me think that they're trying to
stop people from using offshore banks
yeah i got a notification on uh some one
of my things of they're trying to do
anti-money laundering stuff they're
really pushing this which i think is the
funniest thing in the world because
they're allowed to money launder
i'm not gonna i'm not saying anything
interesting somebody's money laundering
we're not allowed to i just keep i don't
want to by the way i'm already in so
deep well the federal reserve they work
with the bank the swedish the swiss bank
for international swedish the swiss bank
for international settlement you don't
know what i think i think i think davos
group i think the world economic forum
they want crypto like a new world
currency well it's it's bitcoin is fully
trackable and uh with with the right ai
you can see who is doing what where when
and how and you can even infer as to why
and uh they're they're all big fans of
it a lot of these global elites i mean
blackrock didn't they just buy a bunch
of bitcoin i don't know i was going to
say i read an article by reading at
arklam and i read a headline that said
yeah yeah that blackrock had bought into
crypto these institutions keep coming
out and they say things like don't don't
buy crypto and then people panic and
they sell it all to them to these
institutions there are hedge funds also
that um a couple i read a lot last year
that were actually telling people with
bigger portfolios to make sure you start
buying crypto now yep it was a couple of
big hedge funds uh
that's just about 2019 blackrock this is
from investopedia blackrock rips bitcoin
uh colon buy crypto only if you're ready
for complete losses which is the quote
and then from two weeks ago blackrock
announces new bitcoin trust
that's the game they want you to sell it
at dirt so they can buy it up now i'm
not telling you what to buy i'm just
telling you i've got crypto and i ain't
selling it i'm holding on to it because
um
it's got its function it's got the
purposes i have a couple different ones
but i i think it's gonna um i don't have
bitcoin because i think it's gonna be
worth millions of dollars i do think
it's worth millions of dollars i have it
because i think it's going to become a
principal utility in the future it's
going to become substantially more
widespread in use and i think the the
global elites are very very interested
in trackable digital currencies
absolutely yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you